How dare you call yourself a journalist,
These protestors are yelling at reporter Tim Pool.
I'm not going to let them bully me out of
reporting on what they're doing.
Pool is part of what some call the "new media"
Reporters who work for themselves
and often cover things the mainstream media miss.
The news you’re getting comes straight from me
and straight from the source on the ground.
That brings them viewers.
More than a million people subscribe
to Poole’s online channels.
Fascist thuggery!
Here, he’s videotaping antifa protestors
who try to stop him
Tim Pool, he's getting blocked yet again
the Antifa de-escalation team,
they actually called it, said don't touch him.
And so, they actually made sure people didn't touch me,
which is good.
Antifa has a de-escalation team?
Yeah, they have people who try and make sure
nobody, you know, no one from their side starts
it because the cameras are rolling
You call yourself a person of the left
and you worked at VICE
Yeah
But now you're mostly criticizing the left.
This really strange faction of people on
the left that are saying ridiculous things
that make no sense.
They're hurting the left
and they're helping Donald Trump.
Trump gets voters who watched those protests
Yup. You look at this protest in Portland,
a Bernie Sanders supporter showed up with
an American flag to protest against the fascists.
And so, what an Antifa do?
Crack them over the head with a club
and put them in the hospital with a concussion.
[Protest sounds]
[Kids chanting]
Pool won fans with his coverage
of the Covington school conflict.
All of these big news outlets,
even the Washington Post, CNN,
they immediately made the assumption
he must be a racist sneering
at this Native American man.
I didn't make that assumption.
I just see a guy banging a drum
and a kid with a weird look on his face.
So, I looked at some other videos
and posted his own video explanation
The initial narrative that we heard from the activists
was that this kid got in this man's face.
You have just seen right now,
it's actually the other way around.
No one else watched the video.
How could that be?
No one watched the longer video?
Nope. Here's what happens.
One left wing journalist says,
look at this racist.
His buddy sees it and says, wow, look at this racist.
And that's a big ol’ circular game of telephone
where no one actually does any fact checking.
And then-- New York Times, Washington Post, CNN
all publish the same fake story
Pool and Reason’s Robby Soave told the true story.
That’s a complete, complete misreading of
the situation. That’s exactly backward.
Pool doesn’t have a college degree.
Or even a high school degree.
I like it that you're a high school dropout.
Yeah, me too.
[laughs]
Instead of going to college and taking on debt
Pool just started videotaping what interested him.
I went to Occupy Wall Street
[Sounds]
The march has begun we’re now at 13th St.
and Broadway for those of you just tuning in
The whole damn system is guilty as hell
He covered riots in Ferguson, Missouri
[Gun shots]
That’s the first time I’ve been fired at
You’re an action junkie.
It's not so much the action but kind of,
you know, I’m definitely an adrenaline junkie.
I've been skateboarding my whole life,
but it was more so --
I want to know why things are happening.
Some people don't trust the media.
I don't know who to believe.
Why don't I just go there and I can see for myself.
And then it turns out there's one good way to fund that.
Tell people what you saw.
He funds his videos with advertising
and contributions from viewers
His most popular YouTube video was
when he went to Sweden to look at so called
"No Go Zones”
Trump had said there are areas where you can't go.
"No Go Zones"
Your video said what?
That it was nuanced.
You got lots of views with nuance?
Yeah.
[laughs]
Pool interviewed lots of people
And they were looting the stores here
and won viewers by concluding:
They certainly have their problems.
But you know, one side will have you believe it’s
the end of the world and other will have you
believe nothing's happening at all.
Pool is now a zealot for free speech
When I was growing up,
it was the religious conservatives
that had the moral panic about music and swear words.
But today the moral panic is coming from "the left."
What happened to the left at Berkeley
holding up signs saying "free speech today"
the left shows up with torches
and burns free speech signs.
That's not the left.
And so, you know,
It is the left!
But
It’s not the old left.
They want everyone to believe that someone
like me who was a supporter of Bernie Sanders
is a conservative that way actual conservatives
look insane.
Pool is one of many new media people who are
changing how reporting is done.
Independent, uncensored
I don’t agree with everything they say,
but I’m sure glad they’re out there.
They give us more choice.